Prince Harry with dr. Jane Goodall and
the puppy I mean words dead the Duke of
Sussex reunited with the themed
primatologist on Tuesday as part of her
Roots & Shoots global leadership meeting
held at Windsor Castle and what a
reunion it was Harry reenacted the
chimpanzee greeting could all taught him
when they previously met and he led her
in an impromptu dance because as Harry
and Megan markle's Instagram account put
it working hard and playing hard are not
mutually exclusive from heartwarming to
hard-working Harry also took the time to
meet with young people who are doing
groundbreaking work in their communities
as part of goo dolls Environmental
Action Group
and he addressed the crowd after
listening to presentations on endangered
species reducing plastic waste and
embracing the wild in his speech Harry
revealed that he first met the 85 year
old chimp expert last year and described
her as a woman of kindness warmth
immense knowledge and a softness that's
needed by mankind just as much as it is
chimp kind and rumor has it even Harry's
newborn son has met at all the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex are huge fans of the
world renowned primatologist and invited
her to their Frogmore cottage home last
month where she reportedly cuddled event
five week old Archie we're a fantastic
team we know real according to one
report the Duchess of Sussex told
Goodall that she was her childhood idol
adding quote I've worshipped you all my
life I never thought my life would be
that awesome and as for Archie Goodell
reportedly called him a very cute and
very gentle it's pretty amazing
[Music]
and I have the two best guys in the
world so I'm really happy